desde muy temprano el día de hoy me
levanté a arreglarme lo mejor posible
para estar frente a ustedes
días antes elegía el mejor vestido que
pude encontrar y me puse mis tacones
bien puestos para venir aquí me peine y
me maquillo de acuerdo a lo que
represento
y qué es eso que represento
a la mujer
pero qué es la mujer
ser mujer y ser femenina son dos estados
diferentes
a la mujer la forma las expectativas
sociales pero ser femenina es elegir
trascender esas limitaciones
hace muchos años se encabezó por primera
vez el feminismo mejor conocido como
movimiento social y político que surge
formalmente a finales del siglo 18 el
cual defendía la ideología de que las
mujeres debían de tener los mismos
derechos que los hombres
empecemos por retomar un poco de su
historia hablemos de la primera ola del
feminismo ilustrado sin contar aún con
un sistema organizado desde finales del
siglo 18 y principios del siglo 19
surgen las primeras apariciones en
francia e inglaterra reclamando igualdad
de oportunidades buscando acceso a la
educación a la ciudadanía y a la
inteligencia
mientras tanto en mexico aparece por
primera vez el feminismo en la península
de yucatán formándose la primera escuela
feminista llamada siempre viva dirigida
por la maestra y poetisa rita gutiérrez
al mismo tiempo en francia en medio de
la revolución francesa en 1791 olimpia
de gouges publica la declaración de los
derechos de la mujer y la ciudadanía en
1793 muere guillotinada por esa misma
causa
segunda ola del feminismo sufragista
desde finales del siglo 19 hasta finales
de la segunda guerra mundial las mujeres
sufragistas dieron nacimiento al
activismo al poder de asociación y de
lucha defendiendo la no-violencia
emily davison muere arrojándose frente
al caballo del rey jorge cuarto buscando
hechos no palabras
en méxico aparece el movimiento en los
años 70 en un contexto social por
mujeres universitarias quienes
cuestionaban las relaciones hombre-mujer
y por último tenemos la tercera ola el
feminismo contemporáneo parte del siglo
20 donde se caminaba con el lema sin
derechos sociales para las mujeres no
existen derechos humanos ni justicia
después de la igualdad al voto
surgen avances de carácter político
social y económico para la mujer
y por fin llegamos al día de hoy a las
mujeres del siglo 21 se supone
deberíamos encontrarnos en la fase final
de la tercera ola enfrentándonos a retos
como aumentar la igualdad de género
disminuir la discriminación disminuir la
violencia doméstica y aumentar el acceso
a estudios superiores
pero donde nos encontramos a nivel
mundial nos encontramos con un alto
índice de drogadicción femenina
movimientos feministas irracionales
replicando actos de manifestación con
sentido prácticamente canibalista
liberación al derecho a la vida cuando
no se ama la vida misma redes sociales
llenas de ladies de polanco y madres
luchonas llorando y buscando a sus hijos
cuando no sabemos ni siquiera dónde se
encuentran tecnología de punta pero
educación de suelo escuelas de renombre
pero valores de basura rechazo al
machismo pero aceptación al feminicidio
enojo a la libertad al vestido pero como
sin y vestido usamos
el 80% de las mujeres se ha olvidado del
verdadero valor de la mujer del
feminismo y si es cierto méxico se
encuentra en decadencia política y somos
atacados por el movimiento machista pero
ninguno de estos dos son culpables de la
decadencia femenina y humana por poner
un ejemplo lo que tenemos más a nuestro
alcance en nuestro estado sinaloa las
mujeres somos catalogadas como mujeres
hermosas banales y narcotraficantes sí
así es
mujeres mucho más como el mundo nos
conoce y lamento decirles que este
concepto nos lo hemos ganado a pulso
nosotras mismas con nuestros actos y
nuestras palabras me atrevo a decir que
en todo el mundo todos los días amanecen
al menos tres noticias en los distintos
medios de comunicación acerca de mujeres
violadas asesinadas o golpeadas y todos
con el tema de tales hechos han sido
provocados por algún hombre psicótico o
por la pobreza extrema o por algún medio
político pero nadie habla de que al
mismo tiempo de tan fatales
acontecimientos proporcionalmente
aumenta el índice de niñas embarazadas
desde los 15 años de edad y madres de
familias enseñando a sus hijas cuan
importantes el verse bien y no el pensar
bien y redes sociales llenas de
pornografía infantil al alcance de
cualquier persona y todo esto por las
mismas protagonistas que lo proclaman
las estadísticas no mienten
sin embargo
existe un 20% de la población que
merecen ser realmente replicadas y donde
caben las mayores responsabilidades
donde debemos de prestar nuestro poco de
atención y ser este 20% tiene ayuda al
80% restante a cambiar el concepto
actual de la mujer debemos dejar de
criticarnos de denigrar nos y de juzgar
a quien socialmente lo está haciendo mal
debemos reunir fuerzas para formar más
científicas empresarias ingenieras
educadoras y un sinfín de acciones que
podemos lograr quieren ejemplos
mundialista obra winfrey creó una
fundación para crear una oportunidad de
educación para niñas sudafricanas que
han destacado académicamente y provienen
de familias desfavorecidas eva longoria
la actriz creó una fundación para ayudar
a mujeres latinas que viven en eeuu a
crear un futuro mejor para ellas mismas
y sus familias a través de la educación
del emprendimiento michelle obama digna
representante de la mujer no sólo con
fin político sino también humano méxico
julieta fierro gossman investigadora
mexicana más importante de la materia
interestelar ya el sistema solar ana de
la reguera actriz mexicana que formó
veracruzana asociación que se dedica a
rescatar la cultura el arte y el turismo
de veracruz después de que el huracán
karl la destruyera casi por completo
angélica fuentes empresarias
chihuahuense experta en finanzas formó
la fundación ponte viva dirigida para
ayudar a mujeres de ciudad juárez los
mochis sinaloa
marta cota maquillista profesional
isabel rivera autor
de joyería al externa diseñadora de
modas rosa maría lópez política y
ciudadana altruista
jenny lópez ingeniera y ciudadana
turista
todas ellas son solo algunas de las
mujeres que tengo a mi alcance
algunas empresarias ingenieras políticas
madres de familia pero todas con algo en
común
sus ganas de ayudar y de luchar por
alguien que les rodea estoy convencida
de que todos tenemos al menos una mujer
digna de replicarse y así juntas
rescatar el feminismo
mi nombre es maría él hernández
soy ingeniero industrial y me desempeño
como maestra universitaria y
emprendedora empresarial
nací en una familia humilde pobre
económicamente pero rica espiritualmente
desde pequeños a mi hermano ya mí se nos
enseñó que si había hambre se tenía que
trabajar duro para comprar alimentos y
que si queríamos defendernos nuestra
mejor arma era la educación es decir se
nos enseñó a que la combinación perfecta
para enfrentar a la vida era la
combinación de ambas cosas
trabajar todos los días y al mismo
tiempo prepararnos jamás victimizarnos
jamás rendirnos y ser siempre
agradecidos pero lo mejor es que como
mujer se me educó al mismo nivel que un
hombre sin diferencias y con los mismos
valores
a mis 18 años de edad mi padre me dijo
hija
tú eres capaz de lograr cualquier cosa
que decidas hacer pero sin importar lo
que es lo que decidas
asegúrate de explotar todo tu potencial
miles sin desperdiciar ni una sola gota
años después esto es en lo que me he
convertido con innumerables retos y
fracasos y aún lejos de estar en lo que
me quiero convertir
pero hace algunos meses después de una
decaída en esta lucha de sueños alguien
a quien amo me dijo el mundo se está
deshaciendo de lo que no le sirve la
naturaleza está reclamando lo que le
corresponde el mundo necesita rescatar a
los soñadores a los defensores a la
gente que cree en las buenas acciones y
tú estás dentro de ellas mi impresión
fue grandísima entonces volvía a
comprender que si somos capaces de
inspirar y de ayudar a una sola persona
entonces nuestro esfuerzo vale
completamente la pena
días después recibí la invitación a la
fase final de este evento y después de
todo lo que les he dicho voy a concluir
con lo siguiente
mujer tú tienes una misión importante en
esta vida
y sin importar cuán pequeña creas que
sea inténtalo
mi idea del cielo es a través de la
enseñanza ayudar a tantas niñas que no
se valoran que no se respetan y que
están siendo denigradas a gran escala y
a un ritmo aterrador la pregunta es
mujer
cuál es tu idea del cielo
yo las invito a enaltecer los grandes
avances que dejaron nuestras antepasadas
ya no a luchar menos de lo que ellas
lucharon y que si queremos dejarle un
legado a nuestras hijas nuestras
sobrinas nuestras hermanas
sea un feminismo real con más
inteligencia y más valores que fuerza
formemos una cuarta ola feminista
nuestra misión rescatar la esencia
natural de la mujer gracias
[Aplausos]